Mike Pompeo is first time on Russian
soil as US Secretary of State fresh from
his tour of European capitals London and
Brussels where he's been trying to
reassure concerned counterparts that the
u.s. is not heading towards conflict
with Iran
now with russia's Foreign Minister this
exchange mr. Pompeo refusing to comment
on media reports that the US was mulling
a huge fresh deployment of troops to the
Middle East we're looking for Iran to
behave like a normal country and that's
our ask and we have applied pressure to
the leadership of the Islamic Republic
around to achieve that we we
fundamentally do not seek a war with
Iran these people really when you get
scared on a problem I hope that reason
will prevail and that rumors about
ostensibly planned 120 thousand strong
deployment which we'd spoke about is
just a rumor Mike said it was a
Department of Defense thing and these
are just rumors which are baseless these
discussions were an attempt to do what
none of his forebears have managed reset
us-russian relations despite a catalogue
of issues where the two do not see eye
to eye from Iran to Venezuela Syria and
Ukraine in a host of topics Iran didn't
even get top mention and certainly no
real assurances from Mike Pompeo that
the u.s. was doing everything that it
could to avoid stumbling into an
accidental war on arms control a shared
desire to renew dialogue possibly
including China and talks though it
remains to be seen if China's interested
and a stern warning to Russia on that
painful topic election meddling
interference in American elections is
unacceptable the Russians were engaged
in that in 2020 it would put our
relationship in an even worse place than
it has been and encourage them not to do
that that we would we would not tolerate
that
Russia's president late for talks with
the US Secretary of State said he hoped
that today's discussions would lead to
better bilateral ties an improvement in
us-russian relations even as the Trump
administration's with Iran take a
worryingly different course Diana Magnay
Sky News Sochi Russia